china con más de mil millones de
habitantes puso fin abruptamente a su
política serocovit a inicios de
diciembre de 2022 generando controversia
y dejando a los expertos preguntándose
Cómo podría verse afectado el resto del
mundo dado que el virus ha circulado en
gran medida por Europa los epidemiólogos
dicen que el riesgo de repercusiones
graves para la salud en el viejo
continente es limitado
tenemos altas tasas de vacunación son
muy eficientes y cubren el 70-80 incluso
hasta el 90% de la población A
diferencia de China hemos dejado que el
virus circule por lo que tenemos un
fuerte escudo de inmunidad y vacunación
pero queda una pregunta si la
disponibilidad de medicamentos
farmacéuticos puede convertirse en un
problema ya que el 80% de ellos se
produce en China o India y la escasez
podría estar a la vuelta de la esquina
la epidemia conducirá a una disminución
en la capacidad de trabajo
particularmente en las fábricas donde se
producen medicamentos además en
ocasiones anteriores hemos visto que las
autoridades china prefieren reservar
parte del stock para su propia población
antes que exportarlo la demanda del
mercado de reactivos de antígenos y
medicamentos para reducir la fiebre se
ha disparado en China y las compañías
farmacéuticas están trabajando A toda
máquina para garantizar el suministro
nuestra producción actual se ha
duplicado en comparación a ac20 días
pero por el momento los pedidos de
medicamentos como el Paracetamol y el
ibuprofeno continuará ya que la demanda
en Europa sigue siendo alta pero la
nación asiática podría reducir sus
exportaciones